BEAR: Let's make a little
nature's candle out of rocks.
DANICA: Get some rocks?
- Yeah.
DANICA: OK.
BEAR (VOICEOVER): Danica
Patrick and I are in the heart
of the vast Utah desert.
She doesn't know
it yet, but Danica
just found us something to eat.
Oh!
Scorpion.
BEAR: We got dinner.
Ah, there you go.
DANICA: Let's not eat it.
No, I'm not-- no.
BEAR: Look.
That was totally what I was
hoping I didn't have to eat.
Don't make me eat a scorpion.
Oh God.
BEAR: Look at this guy.
Scorpions, they can kill you.
Enough venom to kill you.
So yeah, I mean,
what we could do
is actually go and
actually look for these.
If we found that under there,
we try and turn over a few more,
see if we can find
a couple of extras,
make a little scorpion kebab.
You dispatch it.
No.
Oh, this doesn't make me happy.
BEAR: It's fine, it's fine.
Don't let him get
away once you go in.
Done.
OK, so that's one.
Try and get a couple more.
DANICA: It was difficult
to take the knife
and drive it into
the scorpion's head.
But this is survival.
And so you do what
you have to do.
OK, scorpions.
Let's find some more.
BEAR (VOICEOVER): The
stinger of a scorpion's tail
it's full of neurotoxic venom
that can cause extreme pain
and, in some cases,
paralysis and death.
However, when eaten, nearly
half their body is good protein.
If we remove the
stinger and pincers
and grill it just right, it
just might taste like something
you'd want to eat.
But we're going to need more
than one to keep us going.
So we're going hunting.
OK, no scorpion there.
This is a perfect place
for finding scorpions,
all of this dried brush.
But don't use your fingers.
Use a stick or a blade.
Here we go, Danica.
DANICA: Got another scorpion?
BEAR: This is a more
substantial one here.
DANICA: More meaty?
Oh, yeah.
He's a little fatter.
Yeah.
Thing is, I've learned
about scorpions--
and for years, I always
used to eat them like this.
What?
And they taste disgusting
because they're full of--
Oh!
--this yellow kind of weird
stuff and really pungent.
It stays with you forever.
But if you cook them and
you barbecue them up,
then it's perfect.
DANICA: Thank God for the
fire because that's going
to make the scorpion
taste just like char
instead of a scorpion.
BEAR: Here's your one.
Thanks.
BEAR: Don't let it fall off.
DANICA: Do you like to cook?
BEAR: Yeah, I do.
I feel I'm really
disappointing you, really.
We should be having nice rosé.
And--
Oh, yeah.
BEAR: Instead you're getting--
DANICA: We should, but--
This is like a downgrade,
I do feel, for your life.
So how do you keep so fit still?
I work out all the time.
I mean, I work out
almost every day.
And has that helped
you with injuries at all?
I think so.
BEAR: And have you had
bad injuries from crashes?
No.
That means you're a
very, very good driver.
DANICA: [laughs] Well--
It's like, you know--
You read--
Never fight a man who
doesn't have a scratch on him.
DANICA: It's true.
[laughs] Did you feel it
was harder for you going
in as a girl to that
world, especially
when you went professional?
Well, I mean, I don't know
if I thought it was harder
as much as I just
ended up realizing
it was harder kind of thing.
I mean, everything from racing
to listening to people say
things about you to bad
days on the racetrack
and how to deal with them.
You come back to the
bus and I'd be like--
(CRYING)
Oh, God.
Why?
36?
I'm so bad.
You know?
And you would just
have these really
flooding moments of self-doubt
and insecurity and yeah.
And so you--
If I'm here long enough
with this scorpion,
I think it's all going to be
charred and burned in here.
BEAR: Should we go
for the scorpion then?
DANICA: No, I was just
hoping that would happen.
Here we go.
You ready?
DANICA: [laughs] No.
[laughs] Oh, gross.
OK.
It can't be that bad, right?
You eat them raw, right?
- Go on.
Come on.
Come on, lead the way.
I love it.
- (SHOUTING)
BEAR: You got to keep it down.
You got to finish.
[laughs] Do it.
There you go.
You got it.
I just ate a scorpion.
Mm.
You seem like
you're savoring it.
Is this--
- Mm-hmm.
No, it's pretty bad.
I can hear you say, mm.
You're like, mm.
BEAR: Mm.
[laughs] Good job.